this was a painful journey but one they
chose to make into the tunnel where
their children died parents looking for
answers perhaps looking for some comfort
having visited the scene for themselves
how could this have happened how could
so many lives have been lost those
investigating the accident appear no
closer to solving the mystery of what
caused the driver to lose control of his
couch this is vexy doll there's no one
particular theory that we're leaning
towards in determining the cause of that
kid were investigating and are still
listening to all the Swiss authorities
have said they may have to re-examine
the design of the small emergency
lay-bys where the coach came to a sudden
violent halt after veering slightly off
the road the consequence of the crash
was that parents had to be taken to the
morgue to see where 22 young bodies lay
to positively identify the children
they'd lost in this terrible tragedy
the Belgian air force transport planes
which had brought grieving parents to
Switzerland on Wednesday returned to
bring the dead and injured home they
flew over the hospital where some of the
injured school children had been treated
a few hours earlier
a convoy of ambulances had left under
police escort carrying those who were
considered well enough to fly home some
of them making the journey on regular
commercial airlines doctors have
described how their physical injuries
are only part of what they've suffered
the memory have been trapped inside the
tunnel with dead and dying friends is
something none of them will ever be able
to forget in Woods Sky News seon in
Switzerland